Adam Sandler joining us on the program
where are you right now
Oh Sandman yes where are you I mean my
yeah I'm in my room wait what is your
room
well that won't the home has several
rooms and every room I can fit in my
room I'm in my room
how big is your house well I mean look
it's it's bigger than I thought it
that's the first time I looked up in a
while it's huge
are there are there rooms you haven't
been in yet yeah it's that big
that's the room that I don't matter
you know what I'm saying Danny can you
work it from home like what are you what
are you doing now Danny I don't work
welcome home because the the children
are around so whenever I start getting a
flow go I hear somebody screaming a
teacher and I stop and I go up high Oh
what the hell is happening there and
then she pushed me or whatever then then
I go back to thinking of some of my
great jokes and I just I can't lock it
down I'm in a bad movie ever I'm like
damn those kids are you are you watching
movies or shows yes yes what do you want
that's last night we lost Steve Martin
Bowie it would keep going on different
movies I keep showing a little old
movies that I grew up with and and some
half of the time it works and I get
excited you know how about you Danny
even watching a lot of movies yeah I
have well no I've actually been watching
some TV shows I watched Ozark I watched
I'm watching this documentary on
Sunderland the soccer stuff
it's a primarily
well they used to be in the Premier
League but it's a documentary Sunderland
until I die which is pretty good so I
watched Ozark fleabag have you seen
fleabag I don't know I know everyone
loves it I see it oh my god that woman
is spectacular I heard oh yeah my wife
loves it
I gotta see this I gotta see this miss
you make kind of misses a lot of stuff I
got a bag i watch what else I you know
I'm gonna watch that too do you have can
you step outside because your your phone
is a little spotty here what's that it's
not working it's a little spotty here
okay let me go into another go out to
one of your veranda Zuri dad I'm on the
ski slope now yeah sorta gave me that
joke one time I was doing Letterman wait
you're crapping out there - Jesus Christ
I'm sorry okay how about this this
better well it is for right now in the
first five seconds okay hang on let me
stay okay there it is yeah maybe it's
bad perception out here okay okay okay
okay you're all right we'll try that
you're good
Thank You Danny sorry about that okay
and then the lights I saw the songs that
you did you did quarantine song and
Dutch don't touch grandma with Jimmy
Fallon
the quarantine song is who who plays
yeah yeah like I called Danny bull up
and I said I've been getting a lot of
requests for songs and I said he got any
ideas and two days later the guy sends
me that sucker
that's called a good song and then don't
touch grandma
that was Jimmy Fallon and he writers
wrote that sounded super yeah that was
fun
let me let the audience hear just a
little bit of don't touch grandma
anything you want to say and setting
this up yeah I
we had to record it separately
and him I was supposed to turn and look
at when I turn that's salmon with Jimmy
phone yeah that was very nice that was a
nice thing it's funny and Thank You
Jimmy writing that sucker fowling can do
a lot of impersonations of musicians
like like he does you he does Neil Young
I think spring Stang do you think that
Fallon could record has he ever thought
of recording an album of these artists
that he imitates absolutely yeah he
could crush that but he basically
basically has he's done so many of the
show they could just put a compilation
together and yeah I mean yeah he can
he's pretty pretty serious most
impressions man oh yeah yeah he's good
but if you were gonna be quarantined
with any comedian who would you want to
go hunting with 100% Norma Karl why well
because we've done it before we've done
it before
II thought he thought
and a bomb was coming one week so we
just we stayed we stayed in a condo
together and he kept on that yet stay
low oh wait a minute he actually thought
it was the end of the world no I think
I'd have fun with long McDonald I think
we get along good together was good kind
of roommate Surrey give and take you
know yeah he's he's pretty funny who
would be tough to be quarantined with of
all the comedians you know a David Spade
would be the moodiest he liked he'd be
the funniest one second and then the
next second he'd be like you know that's
my toast I'd say I didn't wear the
neaten it's Passover then he'd say
what's Passover and then I'd have to
explain it again well plus there's no
women around to say be in a bad mood
because of that as well did you ever
work with guys no I just forgot his name
Dave Chappelle did you ever do anything
with Chappelle I know but we might do
something someday
of course rocks been talking to me about
to leave the three of us so we'll see
diagnose I know Chappelle since he's a
kid and he was always a great kid and I
remember when I did Billy Madison I did
that with this guy Bob Simon's his
producer he's the guy who got it all
going for me and in the movies and like
a couple years into a we were at Bob's
office and Chappelle and I think he
might have been his buddy Neil game were
at the office and they were making half
baked with wood Bob and I remember just
just seeing how excited they were just
like I was young young and excited you
know I see I see Chappelle along on
occasion but we've never done anything
yeah I saw him he
he won the mark twain humanitarian or
humorist whatever it was it was the Mark
Twain warrant and they had all those
comedians that came out and paid tribute
to him yeah yeah but the fact that he
walked away for didn't go to Africa for
12 years or something I don't know then
came back and took over yeah he's great
he's a good guy trying to grow smarter
sell and yeah that's on that's what's
right yeah yeah it's it's pretty good
there were some pretty funny stuff on
there are you
I did not see Chris Rock on there I saw
Sarah Silverman oh yeah yeah there was a
there's a whole group of people that
common was there doing a song and like
they're just it's a wide variety of
people who paid tribute to him speaking
of Sarah Silverman nice I was in a
benefit charity poker game sadly and and
he didn't see anybody because it was on
the internet but you just saw that names
know who you were playing against and
honey Chester that Paris Hilton was
unbelievable at poker huh yeah she was
way up there on the board she had some
she was leading the pack for a while but
you never dated her growing up right no
no no I knew her her sister was she was
in my class and now we never dated like
that that I knew the supplements very
well there is very my parents and Sharon
Louis parents were good friends too so
oh yeah
hilarious great people do you have can
you shoot hoops at your house well it's
funny I can but I haven't been I stopped
the last month I just stopped playing
cuz my back and knees were Asian so much
so I haven't been doing how about you
Danny moving around at all just smoking
cigars well at night I smoke cigars but
in tequila but you know I got the man
cave here I got the I got my my dojo I
mean it's unbelievable
it's unbelievable you know what I did
last night
crank music and watch my wife stretch
come on stretch you need to I kept on
yeah doing the great you're doing great
yes correct
don't you like that damn you're an idiot
and what did you crank I cranked oh I
put on spotify pop hits so I played the
youthful tunes that were going and
singing I never mind you missed the joke
you know you're cranky
they're always like what are you doing
so your mom never said Adam what are you
doing in there are you cranking I do you
need a care package we have some new
t-shirts I know that you only wear
t-shirts we have some we got a Tom Brady
t-shirt
it's called tompa bay wow that's cool
that's cool yes I want that you want
larger extra large double X no yes have
you let yourself go no I didn't mean
what do you what he's forced away at 511
185 okay well then I are you at two
spins um I would say like yes right now
to 208 right now and and I wear double X
t-shirts
anywhere what's right no we're uh when I
was you know going through all my stuff
I was down to 188 and I was immediately
do Matt you're extremely high you're
what six - yeah yeah I was doing medium
and then now I I'm back up to large so
I'm 198 what is your belly button
showing in the medium though no I
actually had like as a 2-pack
by the way I got this new act and I've
been doing it I just not eating right
but I'm doing pretty good it's called
just six weeks and I push ups and sit
ups and chin ups and stuff yeah
and man am I not gonna push up sound but
I I can't believe it yeah but you're not
doing it no I am doing oh oh I
understand how good I look if I lost 60
pounds I would look so good right now
but my object my arms are tight as hell
my pastor told you I just I just it
covered in a little thick skin right
what else are you doing today what's the
schedule today at the sanding so I'm
gonna talk to the safty brothers and
we're writing right now
and another movie after movie I'm doing
a hopefully that I talk to you about
you're gonna be part of it's a it's a
playing a scout I scout i Scout a kid
from over in Spain I'm a basketball
player for NBA yeah it's cool it's cool
alabanza produced and and so I'm doing
that how often you talk to lebron about
this leave me and LeBron I'll talk about
it which is just a head nod I don't want
to bother LeBron right now he doesn't
know he's not doing anything
leave LeBron oh let him rest
he's got he's got stuff coming you have
do you have LeBrons number I don't think
so
I don't think so I think if I made a few
I've made a few phone calls I could lose
at least three a decision I could get it
maybe a two one three or two
no I'm sure I could get LeBron sniper
he's a good dude we're good to each
other all right so you're gonna talk to
the safty brothers you got another
project you got another movie or two I
got a great a zoom call going tomorrow
night you want to get on with who it's
all comedians
know why it shouldn't be on a call with
comedians yeah PTA
gonna be on it to who I texted yesterday
come on come on come on the call it's
gonna be fun we're zooming away
comedians PT a Teddy from from Netflix
who loves ya thank you big big deal
there yeah alright maybe but Paul Thomas
Anderson by the way PTA for those in the
inner circle there didn't did he respond
to you that I wanted him on the show
hello and then he said where are you
when we're talking I said we're zooming
Tuesday night so kind of bringing up
Tuesday sounds like it's a no but all
right I'm gonna send you some shirts
here I don't know if I have double X but
I don't know it's not a note yeah I want
X I'm gonna give you X L Z's motivation
here I need you know it'll be said well
how about you send me one of each
okay just one of these like but the
bland color make the double x and then
the color you know I would love make the
exhale but but I literally I wore XL
maybe in the last 25 years I know maybe
maybe three or four months of that I got
down to the right wait for an exhale
what pants do you have on tonight
right now this shorts in issuance is
really the string is broken but the it
sucked it I've been doing laundry here
you know I'm not good at doing laundry
said that and why you days literally and
now all the sudden I'm doing my laundry
everything's shrunk and tightened
disgusting and people scream at me let
me do it just don't touch the machine I
don't think your clothes are shrinking
[Laughter]
yeah you don't don't don't don't hang up
on me yeah yeah I did so good yesterday
up until around 11:50 and I saw this
giant bag of chips but on the top of the
bag it said less and I couldn't read
something boys like most people ask
Jayda baggage chips I pitied about 3/4
of it and then I left some crumbs for
they keep cranking and in all and I'll
talk to you soon
say other than that I love you and we're
gonna do a zoom cabal right yeah sure
put me on zoom it I'll try to help all
right
that's Adam Sandler